i appreciate you talking to me about
this
i really found this movie surprising and
unexpected and so interesting and i
appreciate that very much
i think that is one of the one of the
many qualities
that honors thomas has as a filmmaker is
that
we're watching something and we're not
sure where it's going but we want to we
want to see the whole thing
yeah i loved that i didn't know where it
was going i wasn't even
entirely sure exactly what genre it was
i loved
all of that i just thought the
relationship dynamics are
so different and interesting
i agree i'm glad you like it i mean it's
not because it's not always the case you
know a lot of the
the sort of two kinds of the cinema i
think that the ones where you get
exactly what you expect and the ones
where you
are surprised and both of them i'm
totally fine but uh
i definitely i definitely like the
ladder
uh myself what was your first experience
like
working and collaborating together and
how did it compare this time
does it change the more you work with
somebody
we've done five films together uh and uh
i think it's changed in the sense that
we have changed we've become older
uh but but the actual the way the the
the
the amount of enthusiasm and ideas and
and calling each other in the middle of
the night uh has not changed
this is pretty much the same we i i do
tend to feel
quite young when i do films with honors
thomas uh
and then really old when we wrap it up i
totally agree with everything the man is
saying
it's uh that's how it is i mean for me
it's uh i always get
i get happy when i when i like
when i feel that i'm nervous also still
because
it's um as a screenwriter i'm not always
nervous
like i was you know when i was young but
when i'm directing doing the films with
matt and the other guys it's a
it's a great feeling to actually care
i mean that you're there and you get
nervous that's just you know you're
doing the what you're supposed to do
was the humor something that you always
wanted in the story or did the humor
surprise you
and why do you think humor is important
when it comes to
telling a story like this humor is um
i feel the same way in life i could
never befriend a person who didn't have
humor
uh it's uh it's unthinkable to me to uh
i mean it's uh um
so humor is part of of life and when we
go the i mean when
bad things happen and darkness descends
uh humor is for me anyway it's uh
very much a part of surviving so uh so
when you tell these dark stories
of course humor has to be in there and
actually matt you
mess he normally says that you could you
could also tell this in a
more sort of uh how i mean keep just
keep it dramatic
and and a bit pretentious but
when you're dealing with these great
themes uh
anyway i couldn't imagine this these
themes
come across uh uh without without a
humor and a little
sugar on the spoon it would uh first of
all perhaps be more banal but also i
i don't think i could watch it nor less
write it or do it
so it's humorous everything to me but
that's also the thing that if you
if you take it on face value that you
really fast end up with a film where
people are aware of their own issues
and that there will be a lot of
dialogues where we touch upon
the the the difficulties of life that
the existential
uh troubles you will face
and and that can end up as not dramatic
and banel but if you
if you stay with characters who are
should we say
um not one-dimensional at all but
definitely they have some very strong
strong characteristics then you can you
can have characters who are not asking
these questions but they're just living
in it
and we as an audience give a gets a
chance to scream at them and say
look in the mirror you know and and i
think that's
that's more dramatic sometimes did it
almost feel like you were shooting
different movies depending on the day
whether you were shooting this
father-daughter relationship or you were
shooting these
oddly you know very violent scenes or
or these group this this group of really
sort of eclectic guys together did it
feel kind of like you were making a
bunch of different movies
but it always does since the first movie
we did together uh flickering lights is
also
there's every genre in there back then i
actually
made it on purpose to because i wasn't
sure i was ever allowed to
make another film so i wanted to try to
make at least one western scene and one
action scene but it's always like this
um and there are days where you think
what the [ __ ] are we doing because this
one
it will never stick together uh it's
very very
especially on this one there were
because we have these highly
dramatically
i mean totally naturalistic drama scenes
and then we have
the gigs over here we have actions and
so it was
definitely it's a it's yeah it's fun
it's it's it's fun to get up in the
morning and see what
what what are we doing today it's rare
that's not a link
to all these youngest in one scene i
mean there is quite a few with
my daughter and me i would say in the
beginning at the hospital
certain things but then again there's
other scenes that could easily be as
serious but then there's one
character that's just annoying in the
scene and then
he gets slapped on the mouth you know
and and that just becomes oh what
happened there it's way too much but but
there is always a little link to the
other showers
within the scene yeah almost but at the
i mean when we shut the ins the scenes
down in the ending
that's i mean and i mean the
like the scene in the bathroom where you
should
stop and i i mean i can't remember what
but we did some comedy scene riot before
and the day
uh before we did some action uh on the
set
i actually had the feeling there that
you know you get a little nervous
right yes i get it well that's your job
i just put my life in your hands and i
just go for it so
you'll figure it out matt i love that
you can go from playing a character like
hannibal
to doing a film like this and then it's
announced that you're going to be a part
of
indiana jones what was your reaction
when being a part of something as iconic
as
indiana jones came up as a possibility
is it were you a fan of those films was
it something you were excited about
i'm very very excited about it and i
know for a fact that uh
sitting here uh i think that's
maybe the film that wanted him to be a
become a director
and and i i re-watched the first one on
the raiders of the lost arkansas it is
so well done it's so charming
and it's such great storytelling um
so yes it's it's obviously it's a it's a
great honor to be part of that the
franchise that we grew up with did you
get to read
a script before saying yes to that or is
it cast and james mangle that gets you
interested
no i mean no i did read a script i
i i i'm in a lucky position where they
do let me read the script before
uh and yes it was everything i wished it
to be
is so so that was just great
when you do something like that do you
feel like you get to make a character
your own much like you do with a movie
like this or
is it very different the approach to
getting
you know embodying a character uh
yes i i do think that i i'm invited in
to create a character i think that that
everybody wants that
that's why they pick certain actors that
they think they can come up with certain
things
uh and they will be a corporation as it
always is uh
but interesting enough again a little
like on a thunderstorm this one right
justice that there is there is a kind of
a genre mix
in in indiana jones always there is
something that is a little larger than
life
characters uh almost back to the 30s of
of the
uh peter law kind of feel and then you
have
indiana jones that that kind of is a
straight man
but but he also he he does produce a lot
of
funny and interesting things but but
there are different character genres in
some of those films
and and that is interesting to try to
find that balance
can you say anything about the character
you're playing in that or is that a
i can definitely do that but then you
will have to find me in a lake tomorrow
with some new blocks on my feet you'll
suddenly get dragged out of the screen
well after you guys doing a few films
together now are you
hoping to team up again is it something
you talk about is it more
just if you write a project and it'll
work for mads like
how do you guys do that i'm done with
him
uh yeah that's it um
i i always i mean i don't it always
takes a little while because
i i i normally i work as a screenwriter
that is my main profession so it's once
in a while i direct the film
uh but i will definitely once i have
something that is
readable try to send it to him and see
if he's still uh
available or if he's only doing indiana
jones from now on
no but it's an interesting thing because
i think we have done i mean
you always find people say just the same
as last time
but but we have touched upon very
different characters now
in our working relationship so
so no matter what that will always be
some little fraction of a character in
there that
a lot of writers you know picture
somebody
when they write for them and then so
so please do that again that's what i'm
trying to say here
this thing because i thought about it
it's it's always with that when
directors use the same access they get
this so why don't you do some other
but you never hear it with a rock band
right i mean a rock band they can just
play for
30 years nobody says why why is he still
singing
is john lennon is john lennon part of
that still can they just
swap them out of course they do get new
drummers because he always dies in the
pool
at some point but there's a convention
there that that you have to uh
sort of change your access but i see it
differently because
especially when you have as gifted
actors as max and we still haven't done
a complete psycho so i'm
we might want to do that all complete
drama
has lots of years ahead of us
matt your career really is all over the
map with the kinds of
roles you do the size of the films you
do you do
films in different languages is that
something that's important to you
is it just you're going where the work
is how
is that for you is it something you have
made a really sort of conscious effort
and choice
in having that kind of variety no i mean
it's a balance i'm really really pleased
with uh
and i would say that it's it's actually
i think all actors would say
yeah i would love that you know it's
it's a perfect balance for me and but
it's unfortunately it's not always the
case for everyone uh
but a necessity
maybe it is a necessity for me to work
in denmark at least
once in a while because it is it is my
mother tongue it is my stories it's my
friends
and and and it's a different feel uh
but i mean if this can go on back and
forth forever i'm just super happy
i will add to that because he's uh he
doesn't know himself
very much he said i know a few actors
that
are so uh mess chooses on the character
and the story he's so much into the
story always and he
i mean he does say no a lot to a lot of
people of course but he always you
always without
it sounds as if you don't know it but
you are very much you know exactly what
you want to do and what characters
that you find interesting and that's uh
and then of course
you will land in in different countries
and different
films but uh yeah
i'm just helping him no but that's true
i mean this the story is the most
important part and then
then comes the character and then comes
the people around you but but
they have to be i mean you have to be
able to communicate with your director
somehow on on
on some level where you know this is
going to be fruitful as a filmmaker what
is it about mads
that and what he brings
i mean do you think do you have him in
your head
when you write certain characters or do
you write a script
and then think oh maybe he would be good
for this and sort of mold it to him if
he says
i'm available to do that first of all i
really don't like the phrasing
have him in my head because i don't like
that idea that
it's a better spot than anywhere else in
your body
but apart from that no i i i honestly i
said before i like to work with the same
people and it's an ongoing thing we
build on characters we've done before
and
a lot of the things i do that i wouldn't
dare to venture into without
uh knowing that i had not only met but
this
the group of actors uh uh uh around me
so that that's the yeah that's the uh
that's the one thing uh but also i'm i'm
also
uh how you say inspired by him
uh and um
and he's he's a good actor i hate to do
this when he's here you know
he's suffering so hard you can tell and
i'm just enjoying
it come on let it out let it out
yes is the perfect actor he is he takes
responsibility for the whole film he can
do what
i mean he is and it's he is he's very
physical
he can i mean see the ending of another
round uh
i mean he he uh he makes people cry with
the uh with
like dancing no not many could do that
this and see the beginning of it
uh where he's he builds a feeling
so slowly in the scene it's uh he is
ridiculously good
so and i'm not gonna say enough is
enough
now this character is not really only
the straight man in the story he's
really the very stoic
man in this story was it ever a
challenge to play that
especially with so many other wacky
things happening or is it just sort of
another
challenge that you approach playing
no i think that it was i mean had he not
been i mean i i wouldn't say
the word story i think that he something
is imploding or exploding inside of this
character from the get-go
and that is very different in story
stork is almost like it's just going
over your head right but that's not the
case with him
something is spoiling right uh and and
and for that reason i think it was an
easier straight man
play than another one who was just
always confused what's happening
this guy my character could always just
he could accept the insanity
for a while but he would cut through it
because he was on a mission right
and i think that in general uh i think
we would have approached it differently
thomas
and me we would have found some other
cracks throughout the scenes in
in the first hour had we not have had
the
the scene in the bathroom where he
completely breaks down and becomes
a a small child who's helpless had
if we not have that scene we would have
done we would have
done different things with the character
throughout the films but because we had
it
we could stick to his his path and and
i think that was uh that was the key key
scene for for
the character what has it been mads to
have an experience like doing something
like fantastic beasts where you step
into a role that
had already been originally played by
somebody else is that a different
approach for you as an actor to figure
out
how to make that character your own or
are you figuring out how to build on
what was already done
nobody's interested in me going in there
and trying to copy anything
that would be creative suicide
immediately especially when it's been
done
before and mastered fully so so
everybody is expecting us to find a
different path
having said that we need a bridge
between what he did and what i'm going
to do so so those bridges we have to
find together
whether it's a certain look where
there's a certain attitude in certain
situations but
but you have to make it your own
anything else would be
plainly just creatively stupid what was
it that made you
want to do something like that because
it seems like an opportunity that
doesn't come along very often
yeah that that is one reason
and uh no i'm a big fan a fan of the
the party universe uh and uh
and it's a it's a it's a kind of genre
that yet you you don't touch upon in my
part of the world it's
it's just no go i mean you can't get
away with that budget twice it didn't
work
so obviously when it came my way was it
was just a fantastic opportunity
considering how many villains you've
played are you extra cautious before
doing another one is there something
that you need to see in a character to
make it feel
fresh and new for you well it's got to
be fresh and new or just a slight
angle i mean there's only that many
different things you can do in your life
somebody said there's only seven stories
in in history right and so so so it is
for characters you will always overlap
somehow
you gotta have this genre might be
different
so the approach will be slightly
different
i don't i'm not concerned with it at all
uh i mean
people are talking about another round
now and so they can go back and talk
about the villain i'm doing next year
and then they're talking about uh
writers of justice now and then they can
talk about
a third villain so i'm not i'm not
concerned at all i would be concerned if
i wasn't working at all so i'm just
really
grateful that is happening andrews what
what inspires stories for you
what started this story what is it that
where do you get inspiration from is it
from everywhere
uh yeah i mean it's most of the times it
is actually from a character
uh it will be a character uh
uh but i i mean
yeah but i mean i tend to uh i mean
it more and more it's becoming themes i
mean which is i guess
it's for a lot of writers is the is
where it all starts a theme that you
want to explore
and it definitely was with this story uh
so it's uh
but i mean it's i'm very uh how do you
say
unconscious about what i do it's it's
just uh
i just try to go along with whatever uh
feels right on the day and and i write a
lot and suddenly
there's something that i want to explore
further and it's
it sometimes it eventually ends up
it's it's a humble way to answer that
one i mean
are you familiar with the gary larson
the far side gallery
yeah yeah and i think understanding has
the same approach to
live there's a certain absurdity in life
that thomas
is constantly seeing often where the
rest of us do not see it
and i think that him he didn't put it in
his answer but i'll do it
i think that is a very big driver of
of everything all the stories he said
he's telling us are you someone who is
writing
all the time and just sometimes those
things get finished and you
make a film or how does that work for
you no
i mean i do have a lot of projects and i
do i do write a lot compared to
some of the people some of the other
writers i know but it's uh
i don't it's not even scripts it's just
like i'll do a scene or
i mean uh i i'll just explore a
character
for instance i'm fascinated with people
that lie to themselves
uh i mean i like if i run into a
uh like uh it can be a lot of i mean
if i get a parking ticket uh i i will
normally
but to get the anger out i'll go home
and write a scene but
that guy who gave me and tried to
explain why he is like he is
so it's uh it's just i like writing
uh so that's uh and
it goes like this actually there's
there's like times for inspiration and
time for and then when you have enough
stuff you can sort of feel i have
enough i have a theme i'm beginning to
have some characters then i'm
very structured and i sit down and i
will try to do it as
a script so uh yeah
and when do you know that it's something
you want to actually direct
uh very early on
i would say i mean back in the old days
i used to say that it's because nobody
else wants to do these stories i had to
direct them myself
stuff but it's uh there are just some
themes that speaks to
me more uh but i mean i've had others
i've had stories like
um in a better world which i wrote first
maybe i think i was half through that
should
do it myself uh when i discovered
there's absolutely no comedy in this
and i and i uh i sort of teamed up with
susan
and finished it and uh so it's
it's very much the good thing about my
life and this job is
until now it actually hasn't it hasn't
been the same two times
uh so it's very that's really few people
can say that about their job right that
it's
it's new every time so
well i appreciate you both talking to me
about this film i really enjoyed
all of these colorful characters so i i
thank you for talking to me about it
thank you you're so welcome thank you
tony craft thanks